I'm Eddie Brock I'm a reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
I have been taking
look around in the world who do you see
the planet on the brink of collapse
human beings are disposable like man and
symbiote combined this is a new race
your species the higher life-form
what do you want me
[Applause]
we cannot just hurt people
a deal I believe so many thankful time
to that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're
steering me right now
cooperate
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
oops
we'll always come at a cost
hey everybody its charlie we got new
venom footage to break down they
released an alternate trailer and Sony
just announced a Kraven the hunter movie
that they're developing so we'll try to
explain what's going on with that
because we actually thought that that
character was gonna be showing up in the
MCU he was supposed to be the villain a
black panther before they chose to do
kill monger so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos there's a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway I'll explain at the end of the
video you could probably tell that they
got rid of that scene at the end and
swapped in a bunch of new symbiote
footage the reason why they do stuff
like that is because action always
translates really well you don't need to
be able to speak a billion different
languages to understand action and
sometimes jokes don't translate well
into foreign languages
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah some of the
comments on my last trailer video were
actually confused by the humor of that
scene like is it supposed to be funny I
don't understand is he making a joke
like oh I have a parasite they explained
at the comic-con panel that when he
first gets the Venom symbiote he
actually does try to tell his girlfriend
and other people they don't believe him
yeah whatever you have an alien parasite
inside you that's the craziest thing
we've ever heard
the trailers haven't done a good job of
explaining the boy who cried wolf aspect
of his character so he's a reporter
everybody knows that but he's actually
in disgrace when the movie picks up
because of a story he botched preceding
the events of the movie so that's why
he's so eager to go after the life
foundation because it's a huge scoop he
feels like it'll make people respect him
again so like there's this whole other
story line besides him just trying to
take down the other symbiotes so you
have Eddie Brock's mission then you have
the Venom symbiote mission and the other
thing that the trailers haven't done a
really great job of is as in
distinguishing how many of the other
symbiotes are in the movie
not including venom there's five in that
original lethal protector storyline and
I've seen a couple of websites miss
attributing certain symbiotes to certain
characters because you do see multiple
different people getting symbiotes but
the thing is is that the trailers don't
clarify whether or not it's the same
symbiote jumping into a bunch of
different people or if it's multiple
symbiotes we see at least three
different people not including Eddie
Brock get symbiotes there's this guy at
the beginning when carlton drake is
trying the symbiote bonding process for
the first time it looks like it doesn't
go real well for him then you have the
female EMT that's actually donna diego
she does get the scream symbiote in the
comics but the scream symbiote is yellow
in red this is very clearly dark blue
and it looks a lot like the riot
symbiote that Carleton Drake gets in
this big battle here towards the end of
the film
this shot here shows only two symbiotes
and even though this light shining on
this one makes it look kind of yellow I
think it's meant to be silver I think
they're just trying to distinguish this
from the Venom symbiote like this is the
silver looking riot even though in the
comics riot isn't silver they're just
playing with the colors a little bit
distinguish him from venom this one
seems like the Venom symbiote I saw a
couple websites thinking that this was
meant to be a yellow symbiote but
there's no yellow symbiotes running
around anywhere in the trailer so I'm
just assuming this is just a light trick
and it just looks a little misleading so
just to be clear this big symbiote that
he's fighting at the end is meant to be
riot which I know is a little bit
different from the comics but they
wanted to show a hierarchy the reason
why he's so much bigger than venom is is
because they said that venom is supposed
to be the runt of the litter
amongst the Clint are they want him to
feel like a bit of an underdog but if
you didn't hear the news this morning
Sony confirmed that they're developing a
craven movie with the person that just
did equalizer too so if you liked
equalizer too maybe you'll like their
Craven movie but by now you probably
understand that venom is meant to be the
beginning of the Sony spider-verse there
are a bunch of movies that are
developing right now the only ones that
actually look like they're gonna make it
to screen or the morbius movie in any
venom sequels depending on how venom
does at the box office
the thing about Kraven though that makes
this kind of confusing is is because
ryan coogler said that he actually
wanted to use Kraven for the Black
Panther villain before they chose to do
kill monger he's an OG sinister six
character they're developing Loki's
sinister six in spider-man far from home
so people just expected him to show up
he's even the stepbrother of the
chameleon who is a character that's
going to be in spider-man far from home
so there's just a lot of Craven things
swirling in the background in the MCU so
the fact that Sony then says hey we're
gonna do our own Craven movie just makes
it totally confusing because the spider
verse that Sony is doing isn't supposed
to be directly connected to the MCU so
anytime you hear about a character
showing up in Sony spider-verse
it immediately decreases the chances
that that person will show up in the MCU
which i think is why sony has not tried
to develop a green goblin movie because
if Sony really likes to make money and
they want to develop as many big
characters as possible why would they do
a silver and black movie over a green
goblin movie it just all seems really
weird so I wouldn't be surprised if at
some point if the Sony spider-verse pans
out and they do continue to make movies
if there's a little bit of duplication
but let me know in the comments what do
you think is going to happen with this
Kraven movie do you think that it will
actually make it to the screen what do
you think it's gonna be a silver and
black situation and it just gets stuck
in development hell but there's a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on the
video there's more deleted scenes that
I'll do videos for next so while you
wait for that click here for that
spider-man far from home teaser learn
about the Ironman suit and click here
for more info war deleted scenes thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]